yeah are they gonna hit me with the bird
the double bird variation okay I did
that when I played white against them
last time okay let's go with nine f6 or
d5 oh let's try negative six again okay
well let's try this
well we have what London London London
London system let's take here now what
mmm
establish a pond in the center get your
knight to c6 get castle get your light
square Bishop out doing something
exciting
let's get night out here first that way
I'd have to deal with maybe any issue
about the knight coming here now that is
a bit weird I guess it's ready to come
into the c5 square what can you do
Wow
since there isn't what's the difference
between Knight d2 and ninth c3 I'm
trying to define the differences between
those two moves
well the knight from c3 puts pressure on
the pond the night on d2 does not so
what does all that mean means that maybe
I could be running with an F 6 v 5 move
or in other words I could like bring my
knight somewhere else and try and get
this move in with tempo a bit easier
maybe about night here there's something
to it
I'm gonna try that
let's see going in Reverse but hopefully
for a good reason something that I could
really rely upon here I have a lot of uh
I'll have a lot of pieces focused on
this square soon enough and it's not
without weakening my position keep in
mind as soon as I do this maybe there's
this pawn push let's go for it
I think I might still play e5 even if
efore is played if I'm able to establish
this is already a highly critical
position okay so I'm not having to deal
with some serious calculations right
there so I did the f6 for a reason let's
get it in follow-through swing that bat
now this Knight is gonna be kicked away
or is he so I could consider this and
the knight needs to find a new home this
Bishop is gonna be a beast still but I
think the space advantage is a good
thing so I'm gonna do it and then follow
up with f5 and then maybe this I think
that's a good idea actually because I am
threatening to get in f4 because of
tactical possibilities on Knight takes
here if pawn push Bishop takes I have
Knight takes d4 and I think I'd do that
right now and if I get that in I think I
stand better and I think I'm now going
to stand better Bishop takes I could
consider actually sacking the rook and
then taking here or just keeping the
material balanced and taking here right
away I'll want to be cautious about the
following if I go for this Knight takes
D this pawn is going to be a bit more
accessible in fact there might be Knight
takes D Knight b3 and if Knight takes
Knight and in between move of Queen
takes pawn with check and only then
recapturing on b3 right here being
one of those possibilities so if night
here in night to be three I think I need
to be taking the light square bishop so
let me do that right now
it takes d4 I'm also on the rook oh oh
oh wait a second I'm on the rook - so
this I'm pretty sure this is turning out
to now be a success I think it's I think
it's very clear right now why it should
be seen as a success for black this
Knight is on the edge of the board and
the position has been blown open here I
have a half-open file these Knights
don't have great squares right now and
I'm winning the exchange right here
actually no well I'm winning material
because I could just take the bishop and
then the rook that's that's that's a big
problem there so now I'm actually yeah
I'm up a full minor piece that's the end
result of this sequence that's it how to
recapture I want my light-square bishop
to play so let's get my knight over here
I don't care about going in Reverse with
my knight my main focus is get my Bishop
out so I could get my rook out and
that's it now what what's the scoop and
I froze it out down I see okay here we
go
okay closed out of a window here that I
usually have open okay Bishop just come
all the way back stick around here stay
developed and I really do just want to
do what
I'm going to do this two reasons one
eventually box out the night once it
occupies the square and two if pressure
is placed on this right now I could play
here and at least get rid of one of
these guys in summary I'm okay with
exchanges more specifically I'm okay
with giving up my light square bishop
for either one of those nights I just
want to get rid of one of them and let's
go for this right now it's a good spot
for my bishop I have this square watched
over I'm gonna play rook to c8 rook to
see for these these squares right here
have my attention
there are a good outpost for pieces for
Brooks in this case or maybe even
bishops or Knights if I get a knight
right here great opportunities great
posts support points you know you could
do this in your these um these ideas
that I'm sharing right here they may
seem really basic but they're their
applications are good they hold in
longer games right here a quick scan
that I would be doing right here okay
first things first let's get down the
only open file and throw the knight in a
pen a quick scan I would be doing is
running as follows I'd look to see which
one of my pawns is furthest advanced and
then I'll look into seeing which squares
is controlling it's controlling this is
the furthest advance what is it
controlling f3 e3 so what does that mean
well of these two which is weaker well
this one okay so this has my attention
how can I get a knight there it's
probably very good how can we do that
well actually how can we keep my
opponent in a pickle is my more direct
question right here how can you do that
you can do that by playing Queen here I
guess I set myself out for it some
tricks but let's do it anyhow because
the tricks that I think my opponent
would
at least result in material being
exchanged I think night here is
available and if I take this queen takes
and then the bishop gets picked off but
I want to I want to maintain this pin
that's why I did this move
I guess the rook can leave and if I take
the knight when I bishop the rook can
come back over but actually that's not
working because I could take this and I
think this is now turning out to just be
the winning well it's already winning
but I'm winning more material now more
pieces are falling I have three pieces
on the knight and there's only two
pieces around to defend and I think I
just sidestep one check and then
everything is quite alright this is a
good way to do it just defend and
welcomed more exchanges so I can't move
my bishop just yet but on now I'm
staying on this diagonal stopping tricky
stuff and now finally I could get my
knight working actually let me just do
this so the Queen doesn't get that doing
anything great
and now finally finally finally let's
get this night doing something now that
my opponent is backed up there is time
for these maneuvers let's just take and
come over here with my rook maybe no
time no time already Queen's are off no
material left anything just move smooth
quick okay good game let's back up back
up to where
back up to what position let me flip the
board and look look at things from your
perspective so this is actually a setup
that I have gone with on the white end I
think more often than any other setup in
chess this right here the London now
what can you be doing different I would
really consider this right well this
right here has my attention because why
not why not go to c3 what's holding the
knight c3 move you know I know I not
Knight c3 instead of d2 I was saying
during the game Knights Knight d2 is
allowing for Knight B 3 and then hiding
the c5 square but you can also get to it
by way of a 4 so I think knight Knight
c3 is the move there and maybe in
response to f6 you should be considering
e4 I think things get really wild but
look into this e4 move I've had this
played against me that's why I was going
against it and from what I recall it
actually turned out to be very very good
for black and in this game it turned out
to be working I think again one of the
reasons for this is because of the
Knights placement to be on D 2 and C 3
and it's because I was able to find
differences between the two moves and
for those of you here watching and
you're you're encountering games where
you're booked up let's say with a
particular variation and then all of a
sudden you see something different right
there what you're needing to do is what
you need to start to look into the two
different well five folks to me find the
differences between the two moves and
then maybe run with a particular plan
against it like like I was saying here
the knight c3 move what is it doing it's
putting pressure on d5 I'm probably
going to need to keep support for that
point but with the knight on D 2 there's
no pressure on d5 so now this is
allowing for me to not only throw my
knight backwards and obstruct my queen's
view actually let me state it like this
it's not only allowing for my knight
to play backwards release control over
d5 and mask my Queens defense of the d5
square well I I lost my train of thought
there it's it's allowing for new
possibilities having your night on d2
opposed to c3 huh how's that for a quick
bailout right there that's that is the
that is the short summary I guess
keeping it simple as best right there
considering Knight c3 you really have to
have a good reason to go to D 2 instead
of d3 okay
all right let's uh that's that's the
main point cuz as soon as I get this
break-in there's no way that white could
be standing better with this tactic just
not seeing it well now it's the loss of
material significant amount so I don't
know what the best continuation is here
seems like I'll be getting the light
square bishop at minimum or the dark
square bishop in both cases things are
good I have a space advantage so I think
make me think twice about running with
this f6 and E 5 idea play Knight c3 the
more natural of the two squares